mike capps was saying one day he said
you gotta be
you can't really steal tk kirkland [ __ ]
because my shit's not recycled jokes
right my shit's like i actually have
lived it
you know like my [ __ ] is for real and if
you do it
you got to have a certain
swag or persona about you you know like
right now i'm talking about how i only
date
um married women and women who are
relationship because i know you hoes
ain't happy they're the kind of [ __ ]
i [ __ ] with [ __ ] can't
and i said one of my [ __ ] i have been
[ __ ] for years died during colby then
we get out of here and i said she dodger
and kovic
and um i said we had to you know
couldn't go to the funeral so you had to
have the [ __ ] on zoom
you know and i said i said the
difference mean a lot of you young
[ __ ] i think you're placing i'm
the type of [ __ ] if i'm [ __ ] your
wife or your girl [ __ ] i can't [ __ ]
your girl and take out of the country go
to turks or caicos rome [ __ ] and come
back and you don't have any gifts i said
that's disrespectful i wasn't raised
like that i said i'm [ __ ] your girl
you're gonna get something when i come
back so the
funeral that we had on zoom
um the young lady died and they had all
their names up on the on the on on the
computer so all of a sudden her husband
wanted to be sensitive on this day this
[ __ ] died right so at the funeral you
know because the mic is live he going i
see him get up and he go walk over to
the fender director
and he said hey um t.k kirkland is on
zoom
he's been having an affair with my wife
over 15 years is there any way we could
block him and the film director's like
look i don't block nobody i don't even
bomb people so when he came back to get
the seat he took his jacket off
and threw it over the camera
now
people may not understand
but i bought that [ __ ] that jacket in
2005. can you imagine
can you imagine how i felt knowing
that's the jacket that you broke through
i bought you [ __ ] you to have
the nerve thrown on the camera
disrespectful
this really happened no i just made it
up
that's the thing like there's some
comedians that will say [ __ ] just out of
shock i believed every [ __ ] word but
the goal
having the ability to lure you in
see i'm a great storyteller 100
that's some real [ __ ] that's hilarious i
had you your undivided attention
the camera man i was like yeah and the
people going to watch it they're going
to be like whoa
then that would kill on stage oh yeah do
it already oh that's amazing yeah